This Bitter  [Music]  what fruit  citizens of the world what I have to say  to you is not something I was ever  prepared to sing  as many of you know by now we are  suffering from inexplicable and  seemingly unrelated incidents  [Music]  ranging from power outages  to the destruction of infrastructure and  homes  [Music]  we now believe these incidents are not  unrelated  but in fact connected  being visited Upon Our Earth  is not of our Earth  [Applause]  [Music]  you're leaving now  I'm keeping keeping safe say for what  your squad was lost in an encounter is  that your only encounter  this is  [Music]  is like the time  we might be all that stands between Life  as We Know It And The anabolic systems  not today  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]